hey youtubers it's Charlie the huge news
is that Warner Brothers just confirmed
they're doing a Harley Quinn spinoff
from Suicide Squad it'll be a team up
like a female-centric team up so let's
talk a little bit about what that's
going to look like they're too big
Harley Quinn team-ups that have happened
in the last 20 years one there's Batman
the Animated Series when she went on the
big tear with poison ivy that was a lot
of fun then more recently they did a big
team up comic book with Power Girl now
there's no way she's going to be teaming
up with power girl in the movies they're
talking about teaming up with multiple
female characters so some of them we
will have seen before in the DC movies
by the time we get to that the thing you
have to remember is that they've just
announced that they're developing the
project like they have the concept like
oh let's do a Harley Quinn team-up movie
sounds amazing so let's start figuring
this out but they don't have a date they
don't have anyone hired to write the
script they haven't really done any of
the larger stuff the studio is just
saying that they're going to start
pursuing this no idea how long it's
going to take to make them if they hired
someone right away they might be able to
get a movie out in like two years so
what I'm expecting is is they might try
to get something going by the end of the
year and they'll sandwich this movie
between the Justice League movies just
for reference Justice League part one is
supposed to come out November next year
Justice League part 2 isn't coming out
till summer 2019 so I definitely think
they've seen the Suicide Squad footage
they really like what Margot Robbie is
doing with the Harlequin character and
they want to get that movie out as fast
as possible so definitely sometime
between 2017 and 2019 just anywhere in
there just depends on when they want to
move films around there's a whole lot of
exciting stuff happening behind the
scenes with all DC's films now there are
a few minor course corrections one of
the big changes that they've had is that
they fast-tracked the Booster Gold film
or at least they put it back on the
schedule but i'll talk about that in a
second let's talk about Harley Quinn
team-ups like who do we want to see her
actually team up with poison ivy right
off the bat I think it'd be a lot of fun
but in order to get to her we might have
to see her in a batman solo film so like
they might try to get Ben Affleck's
Batman solo film out first introduced a
whole bunch of characters they want to
use in other films like poison ivy
Batman's rogues gallery is enormous
introduced more new characters during
Justice League so they just have a lot
more choices with these spin-off films
like you don't have to keep introducing
five new characters each time you have a
new film no idea how much Ben Affleck
would appear
Batman is kind of like the Iron Man of
the DC Universe right now like the
Robert Downey jr. that they just stick
in all the films because he's doing so
well Batgirl would be a lot of fun Jena
Malone was supposed to be playing a
version of Barbara Gordon in Batman V
Superman her scenes had to hit the
cutting room floor but supposedly she's
going to be in the extended version of
the movie so we don't have Batgirl yet
but we do have Barbara Gordon so it's
pretty easy to jump through that hoop
during Justice League so we know we're
gonna have a lot of the Gordon family so
if they wanted to they can totally do
Batgirl eventually and I think that is
part of the plan they just they don't
have a timeline for it yet satana would
be awesome but they haven't really done
magic yet in the DC Universe I think
Suicide Squad is gonna push into that a
little bit a big movie version of the
Dinah Lance canary would be awesome like
a metahuman Black Canary I don't want to
get into spoilers from arrow but there
have been some things that have happened
with TV Black Canary this year but this
video is really just talking about
awesome characters that they could throw
into a Harlequin movie that you would
have some fun with Catwoman would be a
lot of fun almost any of the female
villains from Batman's rogues gallery
just a reminder though the only female
villain characters that will have the DC
Universe that they will have been
developed after suicide squad or katana
enchantress and Amanda Waller I'm
considering her a villain it would be
fun to see her pop up in a Harley Quinn
movie but it's not like she and Harley
Quinn would do the thelm and Louise
thing let me know in the comments though
which female characters from the DC
movie universe do you want to see Harley
Quinn team up with thinking of a team
that's a little bit smaller than the
size of the Suicide Squad so at least
like three or four characters so I
definitely think they'd bring katana
back I think they try to get in
chantress back it depends on what
happens to her in Suicide Squad we
haven't seen the movie yet so we don't
really know what's going to happen to
the characters after but I think it's
fair to say that most of them will
survive because if everybody loves Cara
Delevingne four instances enchantress
they're gonna want to bring her back for
more movies and there will be Suicide
Squad sequels but this Harley Quinn
thing is completely separate it's like
its own thing what about Booster Gold oh
i know i mentioned that stuff happening
behind the scenes big pivots happening
in the tone of some of the films so
Booster Gold is back on the schedule now
it's not supposed to be a team up it
sounds like it's just going to be an
origin story for booster gold and then
he'll slowly integrate with the rest of
the DC Universe if you've never read a
booster gold comic book futures end is a
pretty solid storyline there's a lot
team ups that he's had with Blue Beetle
those are mostly about comedic relief
they're making it sound like the Booster
Gold movie is just designed for his
character and we're not going to see Ted
Kord in it may you know maybe Easter
eggs for Blue Beetle but it's not going
to be the big team up movie we thought
it was going to be the person who's
writing it is acts tensed the person who
wrote the latest episode of the flash
from last week the funny thing about the
DC Universe right now is is because they
don't have a Kevin figure like a
single person driving the tone of all
the films kind of course correcting
everything but like this grand unifying
vision is that people be talking about
maybe Greg Berlanti becoming that person
because he's amazing with characters we
have Zack Snyder who's producing most of
these bigger Justice League related
films then you have all these other
directors doing their thing so you have
a bunch of different people all kind of
doing their own thing so from an
organizational perspective is obviously
vastly different from the way marvel
makes its movies but let me know do you
want DC to have like a single person
like a Kevin foggy figure informing the
way they make all their films so I'll
just be really interested to see how
this shapes up but I'll keep doing
Harley Quinn's Suicide Squad videos as
we get new stuff there'll be more
Suicide Squad stuff happening this
summer because that movies coming out
right at the end but be sure to
subscribe to get everything I'm still
working on the game of thrones QA this
week is like a big battle royale on the
flash so it's gonna be crazy and for
those asking about legends of tomorrow
just to talk about that for a second
careful for spoilers from this past
week's episode of legends of tomorrow
they've kind of done a similar art to
doctor who the end of time which was
david tennant's last Doctor Who story we
all know Arthur Darvill played Rory
during matt smith's run on Doctor Who so
there's a lot of similar Doctor Who
things happening Captain Cold seems like
he died on the series but he signed an
overall deal with Warner Brothers
television and he's going to be a series
regular on all of the DC TV shows so
expect some sort of time ey me
explanation as to how we continue to see
Captain Cold even though he's dead on
legends of tomorrow but they did name
drop a giant thanagarian army that was
going to be attacking Earth that was the
whole reason for them helping Vandal
Savage that makes me think that the
mystery character that's going to be
appearing in the finale is going to be
Adam Strange because he's a big
character during the ran thanagar war so
just remains to be seen but I think
that's what they're talking about when
it comes to
to this big thanagarian threat so those
are just my quick thoughts on legends of
tomorrow this past week in the really
cool news is the Warner Brothers invited
me to go on their DC Comics studio tour
they have a whole bunch of props and
studio exhibits it's open to the public
but they're having a press day they
invited me to come so i'll do a bonus
video for that sometime later this week
i'll see if i can run away with some
kryptonite gauntlets but why you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for last night's Game of
Thrones and you can click here for my
flash trailer for this week thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight